de nos jours ce soir avec ian 23 c'est
ça ton pseudo annoncé call of duty
journal 23 rue
cj 23 sinon c'est bien on rigole yann on
est donc avec piano aujourd'hui sur un
enfer john sting faire il ya trop de
faire donc non ça va le faire oooh
j'en fais mon affaire
ces jeunes boudent plus à faire c'est
parti jan
alors le but voir c'est extrêmement
simple on est sur un nom un tournoi
presqu'à thomas médiévale d'accord t'as
perdu déjà [ __ ] et on prenait sur un
monocycle et déjà fait et le but c'est
au tos a vu partout quel match
exceptionnel je suis énorme
ok j'ai compris pas trop je comprends
rien bah moi je m'en bats les c est ce
que tu as vraiment compris comment
avancer je suis moi pas trop bas voilà
il me plaît bien moi il plaît bien lui
c'est un hipster tenue tout ce genre de
gars qui coupent des bûchettes h ou en
bouchons
oui ok ce parti a new way c'est ça
c'était beau
pardon elle est à venir m'attaquer c'est
scandaleux voilà je pense quoi c'est la
défense il ya un an le jeune danseur
mouillage est assez bon et la la la la
human target gagné chargée au tc des dcf
des fiches de m
comment je suis allé le chercher au ras
du sol tu m'as route c'est comme ça
qu'on fait ou [ __ ] si je crachais
d'allogènes à merten balle et puis j'ai
un ballon à l'eau tu me jacques non avec
un jeu de mots combo jeunes monos
rarement là c'est plus de points à yahr
d'accord tu t'es sacrifiés pour rien
entre mamans la pluie tombe sur toi par
contre c'est géraud kretschmann si tu
veux savoir
avec sa petite tache il est là fais
attention à la marche
ce n'est pas validé aussi je t'attends
bien jusqu'au lac est juste comme il
faut
oh oh oh oh allah et c'est comme la
victoire ce soir là tu vas tu as pas
payer ton pain au chocolat billard à
mais rien racle rien que crypte à la
force du clis abuser oh là là le motif
j'ai pas encore bien que la force soit
avec moi mais avec le palais tue plus
que tu peux rien tu peux rien faire je
peux pas rien mais voilà c'est pas vers
plaît
poulot haut
pas là ce groupe posthuma gueule victor
route de pont puisse lâcher avec l'ail
haché avec la loge n ya rien faire tu
pourras rien faire j'ai l halogène et
d'être auditées par rapport au dollar à
plus qu'étroits partout attention aux
les balles et est mort et je vais faire
matrix regard jean mas félix à nairobi
d'accord je vais lâcher et le ballet et
le l'halogène c'est dégueulasse c'est
dégueulasse ça tu vas pas te voir où les
eaux c'est bon j'ai esquivé la musique
dans la peau aulas le petit bout de haut
le boulet qui tu enchaînes pas non
personne n'à rigoler réveil brasser
large and mail retour de la nos jeunes
mais qui convient de faire contrôler
allogènes vas-y moi je voulais je pense
que ma tante hagen est extrêmement jolie
llano matin tant qu'enjeu reculer km
nagés qui s'est jouée à héric manusset
glissé son nom
attention la loge est notablement lahlou
jeunes à cela un petit un petit côté
mutin je trouve c'est jean luc reichmann
cet avis du haut rhin stockés à la lila
balageas veille pas relevé sur la chaîne
bien mieux bien joué monsieur c'était
beau c'était gtp attend sa bonne chose
je me déshabille
bah voilà fallait pas mal de mes pack
all à vitrolles je tentais rejetant 4ème
quoi j'ai une pensée pour tempérer
appréhendant la rame
oh non ça c'est la même catégorie que
l'halogène et claude rigaud les blacks
se plaît ce giga de ram au plat ou plat
au général au nom mais il a refait le
coup du moulin jansch propose celui qui
gagnent ça l'est tout gagné et tu sais
quoi celui qui perd il se fait pincer le
ttt d'accord avec ça y est c'est parti
gérard ella attend déjà je la tourne
dans le bon sens oui ça commence bien ça
sans limitation du téton être morte et
on
il tente et le poulet il tente le coup
du poignet c'était la diversion ce oui
oui j'ai vu chez gagner entre la ramener
ça va troubler mais pas en dessous
hu jia
ouais
c'est un peu la remise des prix mais
version en outre allez allez allez
ok ce n'est qu'une blague pas il a fait
une brute iranienne
merci merci merci beaucoup
c'était vraiment fantastique très drôle
très drôle un bon match aussi en fin de
cdd au sur 1 de faire faire du rafting
profession n'en a rien à faire ou sebha
au gt j'essaie de trouver une bonne
logique
moi je suis faire sonner sais pas mais
vous savez a pu aller voir la chaîne de
ianu alias et j 23 sur les internets de
l'internet sauter d'une prochaine mrc le
regarder sur tout le monde il faut
partir
pis urines
oh